so listen sad news for fans of the
format my 30-foot microphone cord was
destroyed in a travel related
catastrophe godspeed to a real one we'll
miss you 30 foot microphone cord and you
will never be replaced except by my new
36 foot long cord good morning Hank it's
Tuesday it just feels like so much is
going on right now like my hair looks
like 2008 me because I I haven't had
time to get a haircut oh my God when'd
you get here no I've been here the whole
time it's kind of a bit within the bit
listen did you know that as of today the
awesome coffee Club has K-Cups backyard
compostable K-Cups and five pound bags
for all of your bulk officey coffee
needs tell your boss tell your office
procurement Services tell your friends
and family who use K-Cups all right
let's uh get a check on the weather oh
you know I really am doing okay I'm just
kind of exhausted and not primarily in
the physical sense you know hey so
listen bud that's not actually the
weather you've just described the
conditions of your internal atmosphere
and the weather is actually the
conditions of the external atmosphere oh
yeah no it's it's it's cloudy now that
was a great weather report I'm super
proud by the way I'm drinking awesome
coffee right now it's so good Speaking
of awesome coffee I sometimes struggle
to feel any emotion like purely or
simply if that makes sense like whenever
something good happens like passing two
million dollars raised by the awesome
socks and coffee club for example I feel
good but then there's like this hint of
dread that goes along with it like
something terrible is about to happen
like the universe is about to even the
score by creating some kind of personal
or societal disaster that I will have to
endure I wonder if anybody else
experiences this or if it's like just a
me thing it could just be a me thing but
there's also this related phenomenon
where I get really bad news and I tend
to deny or minimize it or else figure
there must be a way out of the bad news
and that is also an inability to feel
something purely or directly right I
guess what I'm trying to say is that for
me emotions just tend to be muddled in
multitudinous and and above all complex
hey Doom I think ultimately that's why I
love sports so much sometimes I just
need to feel in a straightforward and
uncomplicated manner like when I saw AFC
Wimbledon get promoted to the third tier
of English football at Wembley with my
dad and my friends and 60 000 other
people I did not feel happiness with a
side order of dread I felt pure simple
joy and then lately every Saturday when
AFC Wimbledon Score first and go one nil
up only to lose 2-1 which they've done
literally more often in the last three
seasons than any other team in
professional soccer I don't feel like
sadness but with a little bit of hope I
I just feel the sadness it's it's super
pure it's not pleasant but God it's
simple I mean like a couple of weeks ago
I flew across an ocean with my kid to
see the football team I love not only
lose a football match to the worst team
in the league but also fail to register
a single shot on Target and yet it was
kind of wondrous I was with people whose
love is oriented in the same direction
as mine the emotions while miserable
were at least straightforward and most
importantly they were shared you know
like usually when you go about your day
everyone you encounter is having a
different day but at an AFC Wimbledon
game after an infuriating loss most of
us were having the same day those
feelings of frustration and
disappointment are certainly unpleasant
despite their Simplicity but they are
less unpleasant when you're not so
lonely in them Hank I'll see you on
Friday